all right so now we are sitting down
June except who's the scientific
director and partner at Indy bio and
will we'd love to hear from you the
impact that Indy bio is having on
biotech and just this explosion of
biotech across the world and why it's
important yeah I think the biggest thing
is that biotech traditionally has been
kind of out of the reach of the average
person I mean you definitely still need
a degree just because you have to study
bio bio technology and and biology
deeply but you have to often be a big
professor or you have to be able to spin
out a company and have a huge network
and and then the way biotech was funded
is generally with tons and tons of money
and taking the middie sees taking the
majority of the company percent wise and
so we you know took a look at the way
Silicon Valley does startups and the
lean startup the fact that you don't
have to start with a lot of money you
don't have to be this big name professor
to start an idea and that really is but
the big problem with that is how do you
get that infrastructure it's always a
chicken-and-egg in biotech for example
like you have to have data and the lab
in order to get funding but if you don't
have funding then how are you gonna
support a date a lab right yeah so we
took that out of the equation by saying
just send us your ideas and we if you
get selected we will supply you with a
lab for the four months and we'll teach
you how to become an entrepreneur and
round things out on them on all the
different areas of leadership and
teamwork and communication that you
might not have been trained as a
scientist so that's we're really trying
to provide a completely different avenue
for scientists to essentially become
entrepreneurs and to direct their own
science and to and apply and bring their
science to the public it's so important
because everybody makes fun of academia
now I don't want to get stuck in
academia I want to do something in
industry I want to actually go and make
and that's so important to actually take
what is being learned and I could
you know and bring it to life and so
just even that essence of like your lab
down there and it's it's a fun space all
the teams are you know they're it's an
open working space and the teams come in
batches so what batch number is this now
this is about six there's a batch six
and there's like 15 teams per batch
mm-hmm just about yeah and so now this
is like 80 companies or something that
we funded 81 and now hopefully we'll be
crossing the hundreds soon yeah
and so that's is it always 250,000
dollars at the moment yes we actually
our first batch actually was less than
that and it was it was kind of a test
and that's does another thing about any
BIOS that we ourselves are kind of a
start-up as well so we had to kind of
learn and adapt to the climate as well
so our first program I believe was 50k
with or maybe it was 100k with but it
was a three-month program and so we
ended up finding out that that was
actually a little bit too short in time
and then also not enough money for for a
biotech start now it's four so it's now
four months and 250k instead of a
hundred yeah and is that for equity for
yes for like 5% equity or so it actually
ends up being about 15% equity there's a
whole breakdown of how we actually do
that and then you're see it's so funny
because sure she'll talks about this all
the time but so much of the money that
you guys even give them just goes to
their rent in San Francisco there's a
little bit of that but at the same time
it's you know it's trying to get them to
really do risk right and and yes it is
it is essentially stipend for them to to
live here while we're doing their proof
of principle studies yeah and so you
guys have had all different types of
companies now food tech farm attack
there's so many different ways of by
attacking the planet so maybe you walk
to walk us down a couple of those cool
alleys yeah yeah so food definitely has
been something that kind of blossomed
right as we started as well so
a ton of food companies are really
phenomenal on Memphis meats being
probably the most famous doing lab-grown
meats but as you saw here today
Tara amino foods not co and and of
course AG as well so be flow and all
kinds of different kinds of ways to get
rid of pesticides in our food production
and then so so food and egg of course
therapeutics we have diagnostics and
medical tools and devices industrial
biotech Ling Grove would be an
industrial applications biomaterials we
do it regenerative medicine it's all
kinds of stem cell therapies two of
which today joint tech and therapy doing
stem cell therapies we have of course
computational data and also neuro
technology is there I mean is there
something that in biotech that you
haven't had yet that you really are
looking for yeah um you know one area is
we want to disrupt the oceans and
basically save the planet right global
warming I mean a lot of our companies
have touched on global warming and one
way or another since such as uh you know
trying to decrease animal or usage or
hey heating of animals and and the
global warming that that causes of
course I'll in Grove at the
deforestation that also causes global
warming but but also yeah the oceans any
other kinds of packs that we can do on
on the world would be a pretty high
priorities and saying no that's that's
coming up as a big problem oh and then
also just you know it's always so
surprising to see where different fields
merge yes obviously in the last couple
of years AI has been huge and machine
learning and we're already seeing that
integrating into health care and we
funded some companies in that area we've
done a block chain company with data
medical records so so it's always great
you know being in Silicon Valley to to
see just all the different things and
then bringing that into biotech yeah
and so that's that's a great rundown is
there something else
I mean Indy bio still yeah yeah cool and
Iberico is there anything else you would
think is important to share yeah I'm
we're just super excited about
everything that's happening in
biotechnology right now and being here
in Silicon Valley and kind of stirring
up the community that then also branches
out globally has been such an honor to
to be in this space hell yes
and it's been an honor to have the
opportunity to work with some of the
scientists and help them become
entrepreneurs yeah it's always it's
always a pleasure and that's all right
here yeah so check them out
any bio Co go ply thanks for tuning in
thank you